the you know a little bit better against
interizaga okay so exciting round going
on and the bard just shot up for lavonna
rooney in there against tyra krishna and
lavon is also
doing very good on a winning streak and
we have a move yeah we have a move and
it's one that david didn't actually
predict yeah you thought you the queen
should step back and uh white should
focus on maintaining the tension and the
balance in the position but now
i rea
ali reza actually disagreed with you and
said okay it's a time for trades yeah
and actually the reason i didn't uh
mention that move is because i thought
with the queen trades where's white
losing his central pawn um okay for one
of black's pawns i just thought this
would fizzle out to a draw that didn't
seem to be
furious strategy but okay nakamura what
is that smile about
i'm i'm wondering can it be the position
i don't think it'll be about the
position oh wow it's because furusia
offered a draw with that last move and
nakamura took it
oh wow uh what is that about
it's hard to say